as Christmas and Hanukkah celebrations
come to a close I'm sure you agree it's
been kind of nice to take a break from
the politics and the noise the
frustration and the insanity that
surrounded us over this past year
now as you look ahead to the New Year
we're reminded of the gravity of the
challenges we Face we've talked about
some of them tonight and it's easy to
feel hopeless when we think about that
what's most important to know is there
is hope because as long as God exists
whose very essence is love there is hope
and since God is eternal and will always
exist there will always be hope
God's love is the light within each of
our hearts and it's the answer to how we
as a people all children of God no
matter our background or our politics
can come together and heal our divides
Dr Martin Luther King said Darkness
cannot drive out Darkness only light can
do that hate cannot drive out hate only
love can do that
now love is the most powerful thing it's
what we in Hawaii call Aloha it's love
respect and compassion for one another
this Aloha this love it's not just a
feeling it's not something that's weak
or passive it's a powerful force that
motivates us to take action to stand up
for what's right to fight for our
freedom and for those we love
it's what motivates my brothers and
sisters in uniform and I to put our
lives on the line to defend the security
and freedom of the American people in
this country
it's what gives us the courage to speak
the truth gives us the strength to fight
for what's right and the humility to
forgive those who've wronged us overcome
our differences and move forward
now life is short none of us knows how
much time we have so as we head into
this new year it is an opportune time to
reflect on this truth our purpose in
life where we can find true happiness
and how we are making the most of every
day subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight